[Music]
news to me
is he the reason Nick Jonas and Priyanka
Chopra are an idol I heard a rumor you
brought Nick and Priyanka together true
are they happy
yeah they're happy well you take credit
for credit you take care you're watching
the Jumanji we're in Hong Kong these two
have a full-on bromance going they first
work together in Central Intelligence
and then went big with skyscraper go so
when you were writing this was the
waning mind was this the guy and was it
no don't ask him that Kevin no oh wow
Tom Cruise said no and and then Mark
Wahlberg said no and then Kevin Hart
said no twice oh do what I gotta put up
with there is also some great stunts in
this movie the crane stunt is phenomenal
you did that 30 feet in the air I was
wired yeah
but I still did it ran jumped off one
take and boom besides action skyscraper
is all about family that's fitting since
last April Dwayne and Lauren hash Ian
welcome baby tia she's doing great
mama Lauren is doing great baby t is
getting big baby jazzy is loving her
little sister run off and get married
did you I did not okay I refer to as my
wife all the time that's a lot of people
like I'm like no easy no rush Big Daddy
alright you both worked with Kevin Hart
Jumanji the next Jumanji is coming out
Kevin's gonna be in it but are you
killing him off oh absolutely
okay that's what I want to make hundred
percent Kevin didn't test well in the
first movie so the our chemistry didn't
work so he's gone
[Music]
[Applause]